crucial day in the Democratic
presidential race voting is already
underway in Michigan where both Joe
Biden and senator Bernie Sanders have
been campaigning in recent days it is
one of six states holding primaries or
caucuses today 352 delegates on the line
Washington Idaho North Dakota Missouri
and Mississippi are also heading to the
polls but Michigan again is the day's
big prize to recent polls show that Joe
Biden has a double-digit lead there Ed
O'Keefe is in Detroit for us Eady
good morning politics is usually about
handshakes and kissing babies but the
coronavirus I imagine is complicating
that effort
how's it affecting the campaign well
good morning Tony here in Michigan there
actually are no reported cases of
coronavirus yet so state officials say
they have no shortage of poll workers in
Washington State which of course has
been heavily affected by the virus they
vote by mail and officials there are be
encouraged to open the ballots while
wearing gloves with polls giving him a
big lead in Michigan Joe Biden
campaigned with some prominent
supporters including Michigan Governor
Gretchen Whitman
there was a show of unity among
moderates in the party Democrats
Republicans independents of every stripe
that's what the nation needs we got to
bring the country together Bernie
Sanders won the Michigan primary four
years ago and needs to win again if he
has any hope of catching Biden in the
delegate race one of the differences if
I might say between Joe Biden and myself
is that Joe bailed out the crooks on
Wall Street who nearly destroyed our
economy 12 years ago as the corona virus
spreads nationwide and with both
candidates in their 70s in attracting
large crowds California congresswoman
Jackie Speier called on all candidates
for president to stop holding public
rallies and large-scale events adding
the candidates must lead by example the
Biden team responded saying it would
continue to closely follow guidance from
health officials but that it plans to
continue running an aggressive national
campaign in recent days hand sanitizer
has been front and center at Biden and
Sanders campaign events we do not hold a
rally without first conferring with
local public health officials Sanders
did not say what
if any precaution he's specifically
taking I'm surrounded by medical
personnel I'm thank you for asking I'm
running for president of the United
States and that requires a whole lot of
work Biden said that while also broadly
keeping to the CDC's recommendations
he'll stop shaking hands along rope
lines after speeches and Biden and
Sanders wake up here today in Michigan
but are set to spend most of the day in
Ohio the Buckeye State is one of four
holding primaries next Tuesday Anthony
all right thank you